[Music]
thanks for coming everybody I'm really
delighted to see you all here we get to
talk about go this really awesome
computing computer language so this is
Deb two to seven building go
applications for the open cloud my name
is Nino Compton I'm a developer advocate
for go on Google cloud platform and my
twitter handle is you know calm
underscore unfortunately I have an
underscore at the end but that's what it
is so if you have questions or comments
or whatever feel free to reach out
during or after the presentation so I
want to start by making sure that we're
all on the same page that we understand
what open cloud means as a term and I
think it's totally fair to ask why do we
care why are we taking time to talk
about open cloud before I do that though
this presentation is really two parts
the first part is I want to walk you
through some of the things the go team
has been thinking about in regards to
open cloud and the programming language
go and then I want to introduce to you a
new library from the go team so first
these questions here what is open cloud
and why do we care well so let's talk
about open cloud first the idea here is
you write your go application or your
application whatever you pick it up and
you deploy it on one cloud and the
thinking is if you've deployed it or
even if you've written in a way that is
follows kind of open cloud principles
there should be nothing that stops you
from picking up that application and
moving it over and on another cloud
making minimal changes and that's that's
really the core of what open cloud means
is I use the term today portable is
another term that that you're perhaps
familiar with and why do we care well
it's actually a really nice thing as
developers to have the choice when we
have more choices you know we can do the
thing that's right for our business for
our team for application whatever that
case might be and that's nice because
you know sometimes cloud a is what you
want sometimes cloud B is what you want
now the diagram up here on the slide has
two clouds you can imagine many clouds
in a kind of multi cloud deployment some
of you are perhaps running some of your
infrastructure on-premise and this idea
of an open cloud application is just as
relevant to a team that wants to deploy
some of their infrastructure on-premise
and some of their infrastructure on the
open cloud for most of this presentation
I'm going to be talking about it as if
we're doing it on public clouds but
really there's no reason why you
couldn't do something similar on an
on-premise deployment as well so now
that we've kind of established what the
term open cloud means for this
presentation and why we care about it
why it's why it's a good thing for us I
want to stop and talk about and go the
language and I want to talk about the
cloud so go is experiencing this
fantastic growth right now there are
lots and lots of developers worldwide
who are choosing a language for their
their critical infrastructure and
they're deploying it on the cloud
there's a lot of fantastic open-source
projects that are written in go
kubernetes docker sto or a couple
well-known examples and it turns that go
is just such a fun language I mean I
think as developers like that's probably
the most important thing it's fun to
write go so as a result right now
there's like an estimated 1 million
developers worldwide using go and many
businesses are choosing this language to
deploy their critical infrastructure on
it and so it's just a fantastic choice
for your cloud workloads but recently
the go team has been doing customer
interviews and thinking about how how we
can make go a better language how we can
make it a better ecosystem what can we
do to continue to help drive the growth
of go and so when this concept of open
cloud came up there was kind of this
open question like what what's gos
relationship to open cloud I mean we
know that it's a fantastic language for
the cloud but what about open cloud what
about this idea of being able to write
an application that you can deploy it on
one cloud and pick it up and deploy it
on another without any kind of
significant rewrites or anything like
that and so that's the big guiding
question for this presentation so why is
developing open cloud applications so
difficult it turns out that right now
of the applications that are out in the
world very few are the kind that you can
just move from one cloud to another
without any kind of major rewrite major
kind of migration or anything like that
and so the question is why is this so
difficult why why can't we just do this
right away and if you think about it the
answer is actually fairly
straightforward from a high level all
clouds are kind of similar right we're
talking about virtual machines we're
talking about databases caches queues
whatever right like it's all the kind of
same thing at the end of the day but the
thing is when you get down to it every
cloud is actually pretty different from
the other cloud and let's think about
why that is well first of all every
cloud offers like some set of services
that aren't necessarily the same with
another cloud each of those services has
its own api's maybe you're doing a REST
API maybe you're doing in G RPC API next
each cloud has its own SDK so you have
to learn that SDK and you know SDKs are
built to be able to do everything that's
possible on a cloud they're not
necessarily tailored to the application
developer saying you know these are the
things that you want to use it's kind of
like the kitchen sink and so as a team
you spend a bunch of time like building
an understanding of like what are the
api's what are the services what are the
nuances of each services each of those
services what are like the really useful
parts of the SDK that we want to use and
so on and you have to build up that
proficiency it takes a while to like
really have a strong grasp of like what
the cloud can do for your application or
how to use the cloud just right and so
on such that if you want it to like pick
up and put your application on another
cloud you have this tremendous learning
curve all that proficiency all that time
that you've invested as a team to
understand one clouds api's and SDKs and
so on doesn't just immediately transfer
to another cloud there's there's a
learning curve there and so what that
means is as a team you know you get
started on one cloud you're deploying
your apps you're under you're building
an understanding of the API is the
services and nuances and so on and that
that results in that you're probably
still running your clout you're at your
application on that cloud
you're running you know the chances are
wherever you started is where you're
still running your code today so I
imagine some of you in the audience or
many of you are familiar with kubernetes
this really exciting open source project
that's provided a number of shared
primitives for you know container
management and so some of you might be
thinking well doesn't kubernetes already
make this possible I mean as long as you
have a kubernetes deployment and a
kubernetes cluster it doesn't really
matter where that cluster is running so
you know if you're on one one kubernetes
deployment can't you just pick up your
deployment and move it onto another
kubernetes cluster and the answer
actually there is using kubernetes is a
fantastic first step to having an open
cloud deployment but it's also not the
last and it's important to think about
why that is so in kind of like an ideal
an idealized world you know we might say
an application looks like this you've
written your Yorgo application you've
put it inside a container you've written
some llamó files such that you can
deploy it onto kubernetes and then that
kubernetes cluster is running on some
compute resource for some cloud provider
and so you know if you're thinking about
it like this you're thinking well what's
stopping me from like taking up my
picking up my kubernetes deployment and
just putting on another cluster isn't
that isn't that open cloud right there
well as part of our customer interviews
and we've been talking to a lot and lots
of teams who are using go try and
understand how they're using it what
kind of problems they're running into
and just kind of the the details of how
they're working with the language we've
learned that teams are under an intense
pressure to be shipping features and at
the end of the day that's really what's
valuable that that developers provide
the business we're able to ship great
features to our users and so while these
teams are fully aware of the importance
of separation of concerns and loose
coupling between a cloud provider in
their application in practice you have
these really fantastic services that the
cloud provider provides you know we're
talking databases runtime configuration
and blob storage these kind of things
they just end up using those services
because after all they're fantastic
services you want to be shipping code
and so the application ends up looking
more like this so rather than having
this
nice loose coupling between layers you
have your application that it's actually
got like these little hooks down into
the cloud provider so inside your
application code you have some
particular SDK indications that are
maybe calling out to the database or the
blob storage or whatever and so as a
result your your nice go application now
has this knowledge about the underlying
cloud provider which really prevents you
from picking it up and moving it on to
another cloud and so what that means is
if you want to write your app such that
you can deploy it on multiple clouds you
have kind of two unpalatable choices you
can either rewrite it which you know we
all know that's a tremendous risk it's
also very expensive or you cannot do it
at all which means well now you've kind
of thrown the whole idea of having a
multi cloud deployment out the window
and this is one of the major takeaways
we've heard from a lot of teams who are
using go in production for their
critical applications so you know let's
think about this we're developers we
solve problems what can we do about this
well you know as a developer you might
say well wouldn't it be nice if all
cloud providers had a fixed API such
that you know we write or we write a
code to that particular API and then
when we want to put it on another cloud
we can just go over there we have a
standard set of IP eyes that would be
kind of nice and it's probably not gonna
happen and you know that's actually
pretty fair if you think about it every
cloud provider is busy building the best
services they can the best taste SDKs
they can and they just don't have time
to be looking over their shoulders
thinking about standardization efforts
so that idea is out the window you know
as a kind of side note it's also really
great to have the choice I mean again
this is the whole idea of open cloud is
having the choice you want to have the
choice to put your code on whatever
cloud makes sense to you to your team to
your business and so on and so it's
super important to have this ability to
freely choose and it's good for the
ecosystem I mean we have these diversity
of service offerings and that makes life
interesting you know new service ideas
are popping up and so on well so the
next thought we might have about how can
we get this multi cloud deployment thing
working is well why don't we identify
some generic interfaces I mean again we
know about separation of concerns we
know about loose coupling we know about
encapsulation and all these things so
what if we looked at a number
api's across the clouds that were
interested in and tried to identify some
shared api's that will work across all
of them well it turns out and this is
again something we've learned from all
of our customer interviews that's
actually a significant time investment
and that means you're spending time
trying to identify like design concerns
rather than just shipping features to
your users which is really what's
valuable at the end of the day and again
you know because you have all these
disparate clouds with all these
disparate api's and all these nuances
that are totally different you know one
clouds newt has this particular nuance
another cloud is that particular nuance
it's a pretty it's a non-trivial task to
identify what those generic api's are I
mean it's doable but again it's this big
time investment so again you have this
pragmatic concern like you just don't
have time to do that so that's where the
go cloud team thought we need to have
something better to fix this problem we
need to have a library that makes it
easy for developers who are choosing go
to write open cloud applications such
that they don't have to throw
portability out the window when they
choose the language they have this
ecosystem that supports them so we just
open-source go cloud yesterday afternoon
and I think and in the core it's it's a
library and tools for open cloud
development and go so what does that
mean exactly well first of all you know
we have this state of the world right
now right where your application is
coded to your particular cloud provider
the idea of go cloud here is is that
same idea of separation of concerns
where you write your your go application
calling into these portable api's for go
cloud and then go cloud has these Pro
Cloud specific definitions for your
database for your runtime configuration
for your blobs storage such that when
you want to switch out clouds or you
want to deploy on multiple clouds you
have this very clear seam in between
your application logic and your setup
code that's actually working with all
these particular specific clouds so
we're starting with some generic api's
for some commonly used services that
includes blob storage my sequel database
access runtime configuration
we're also releasing an HTTP server
that's configured with distributed
tracing health checks and requests
logging something that we think every
NGO developer is going to need projects
open source on github like a mission
it's released under an Apache 2 license
you know as an engineer though I'd love
to love to tell you more about it but
honestly I think the best way to
communicate what go cloud really is is
to show you some code so joining me on
stage right now is Ross light who's the
tech lead of go cloud and he's going to
walk us through a demo all right thanks
so you know hmm
all right hi everyone I'm Ross light I'm
the tech lead for go on cloud and I'm
really excited to be showing you just a
small taste of what we have inside of go
cloud so I've got a terminal here up in
cloud shell and we've got some go code
and what I'm what we're going to be
building and you know sort of stepping
through the code of is getting a blob
storage just looking at one of the
generic api's and sending a blob onto
blob storage on both s3 and GCS so let's
go ahead and run this all run go build
I'm I mean V go hahaha go build all
right so that'll crunch a little bit
here it's going to download all the
dependencies and get going alright great
so if we look in here we now have a new
upload binary and I'm going to give it a
picture of a gopher that I had here and
this is uploaded by default this is
going to AWS so I'm going to do AWS s3
LS I already created a cloud bucket
beforehand and we see that we now have
this gopher dot PNG file that's in here
ok so that's great that's about what we
do with the AWS SDK right now
so let's see how this is working under
the hood so I'm going to open our main
go file and for those of you in the
audience who may not be familiar with go
don't worry too much about the syntax
here I'll be talking through sort of the
higher-order concepts so we have our
main function here that has our command
line flag at the moment it's defaulting
to AWS and then we have some setup code
here this calls to a setup bucket
function which takes in the cloud the
bucket name we'll get to that in a
moment but then once we have the bucket
setup we're then using gos generic IO
utilities to read in a file from the
local file system create a writer on to
this new bucket and then writing to it
using gos standard i/o into yo dot
writer interface and then closing it out
and if you have looked at go before this
will look very much like opening up a
file to you so a lot of the magic of
what go cloud is doing is all in this
setup bucket function so let's take a
look at that and that's in our setup go
file so you'll notice that this imports
our go cloud packages it also implements
or imports the AWS packages as well so
in our setup bucket function you'll
notice that it's returning blob bucket
this generic type that is coming from
cloud we are able to just switch between
each individual cloud and return
something that implements this generic
blob bucket type so in our setup AWS
function which we just ran it gets
credentials and does other cloud
specific things and then get calls yes
three blob open bucket to get the
particular implementation that's the
generic one that we want we can do the
exact same thing with GC s and GC P so
in this case we start off with getting
the GCP credentials we create an HTTP
client that's authenticated with this
and then we finally just create or
open a new bucket that's configured for
GCS so as Eno mentioned before the
critical part of this is that what go
cloud is giving you is the seam between
having your cloud specific code your
cloud provider specific code and your
generic abstract application logic so I
let's go ahead and see how we'd use this
exact same application logic
let's try uploading to GCS now so I will
use gsutil LS I've got another GCS
bucket that I've set up here and right
now it's empty because I haven't put
anything in it and if I run upload and I
give it the new flag to activate the new
code path that we put in I'll then give
it my image of a gopher and all over on
GS util LS and look there it is so what
we've just seen is this exact same code
for being able to copy a file from your
local file system onto blob storage with
no change in application logic has just
happened just by changing the setup
configuration so that's enough to sort
of see the simple concepts here but
let's let's see some of the other
aspects of how go cloud uses this in
production because this is just you know
this is a command-line utility we're
usually writing kind of more server code
so I've got another version here of the
same code so if we list the directory
we've got main go and setup go I'll pull
up in setup code but it's exactly the
same as the previous time that we show
we'd have setup bucket it sets it up
with GCP and AWS but the new fun stuff
here is in our main go so if we look
down here in our main doc oh we start
off the same way of having you know the
cloud argument of whichever one we want
and then we have our setup bucket
function but then we use the
pre-configured HTTP so
that Ino mentioned so we set it up with
a couple options in this case we're
having a request lager which is another
part of go cloud and we're setting it up
with Apache style logs being sent to
standard out we then have a series of
health checks that we could use which is
really useful especially when you're
running your code against a load
balancer or inside of kubernetes to be
able to communicate with it whether or
not your server can actually handle
traffic so we create this we signed it
variable s and then for the rest of this
this is mostly just a standard go HTTP
server of we have we set up our routes
we then configure the server we then you
know tell to do the listen and serve
loop the only thing that's new that
we've changed here is that instead of
reading directly from the local file
system we're now reading the data coming
in from an upload file we then read it
in and then send it back so then the
writer and everything else below so
creating the writer and writing it out
and closing it it's all the same before
we just add a little bit of HTTP error
handling all right so enough of me
talking let's see how this works so I'll
go build house before great so now we
have this upload server so I'm going to
start this off with GCP run that alright
great so we've got our initial message
saying that we've started a server on
8080 open a new tab here oops that's a
little small
right
so we will let's run a couple requests
against the server that we just so I'll
do the the easiest one possible of just
listing at localhost:8080 and this gives
us back in HTTP 200 so if we look back
at our first tab now not sure where the
font size decreased but we now see right
off the bat without us having to do
anything more than just saying hey we
want it to go to standard out we now
have Apache style logs giving us hey we
got a TP request in 200 and if you were
running this on gke this would
immediately be sent to stackdriver and
give you immediate logs for you know
being able to observe what your
application is doing in production set
metrics etc so back over here let's try
something more interesting so let's go
ahead and upload our file let's say oh
let's get exciting in it just upload our
source code to GCS I'm sure it'll be
fine
so I'll do upload localhost 8080 slash
upload because I'm in the wrong
directory hahaha
alright so okay cloud a session demo -
there we go
so we'll upload that there and it gives
us the right response and says that it's
200 ok if we look back over here we see
that it's done I upload post giving us
back 200 so if we now look at our GCS
bucket ask go cloud bucket
great so now we see both we have we have
both the gofer dot PNG file that we
uploaded before and we also have the
main dot go now to just really bring it
home here let's go ahead and try this
server and you know pointed over to AWS
and do the same thing so again what
we've done here is the application logic
of the handler hasn't changed at all all
that we've done is changed the blob
bucket that's going through so now when
I go to upload this same thing running
the server it runs we see this a request
log has gone through to the server and
if we do AWS s3 ls3 cloud bucket tada I
mean go so this is just a small sampling
of the features that we have in go cloud
I encourage you to go to the github
website to see more go back here to
those slides so we've just seen blob
storage but go cloud has many more we
also have support for runtime
configuration my sequel database access
request logging health checking and
tracing so this is all available this is
all online and you know it's gonna talk
to you a little bit more about what you
can do to get involved and get started
you know
okay Thank You Ross so I hope that
communicates the power of having a very
clear seam between your application code
and your setup code because when you
have that seam all of a sudden this
dream of being able to write your clot
your application once to pull it on one
cloud pick it up and to put on another
cloud becomes much more feasible now
again these are the supported api's that
we're starting with there's still a lot
to be done this is just a very small
step into getting to that that world
where we can have this beautiful open
cloud multi-cloud story so there's a ton
of stuff going on at the conference
right now there's a lot of exciting
ideas you know there's the launch of
native which is really cool especially
in this open cloud story and a lot of
interesting things to be thinking about
so as you walk out of this room if you
forget everything I want you to at least
remember these three things about the
presentation today so first of all go
cloud helps you develop an application
that runs on any cloud and that's the
big deal here we won't go to be this
great language to choose if you want to
have portability across clouds second of
all we're starting with support from
Google cloud platform and Amazon Web
Services with more to come in particular
we're going to work to have as your
support on its way and finally we're
looking for feedback from everyone
understanding more how each of you are
using go and how you're using it in the
cloud world and how you're trying to
achieve multi cloud is going to be a big
part of making sure that the API is this
go cloud expands and grows are the ones
that are actually useful to the use
cases that you're all encountering right
now so go jump up on github check it out
here's the URL it's under Google the
Google org slash go - cloud we're just
starting there as we're thinking about
is it's growing finally we've written a
blog post about it today that kind of
summarizes some of the ideas that we've
talked about today and walks through
some of one of the examples but I think
really the best way to understand what
this thing is how powerful it is is to
actually like go through the tutorial
we've got up on the the github repo and
try to build some stuff or try to bring
it into your application and see if it
actually works
let us know what we're
let us know what doesn't let us know
what's missing we're doing all
development on github so you can send us
issues you can send us PR straight on
github you don't have to worry about
Garrett and so on a small thing anyway
so I'm excited I hope you are all are
too we're just starting here and we're
really hoping you can all join us and
we're going to build this great open
cloud story for go so thank you very
much
you
[Music]